from The Daily Mail Las Vegas teens
Jesus Ayala and yasmir keys laugh in
court and give the finger to the family
of police chief they filmed thems mowing
down and killing you remember this video
a that went viral They're laughing in
their car filming it and they Ram this
guy from behind and they're in court and
they're laughing about it dude I'm sorry
evil around they're just yeah they just
don't care about anything or any outside
the CL out as they were being walked out
basically still laughing well they were
laughing just sitting there well I find
yeah I I don't know how you I mean I
think it's important to be able to
understand how people get to this point
and how this happens but I also think
that we've and I think evil of course
has always existed I mean you could go
back to Genesis like it's right there
you know um killing your brother for
jealous because you're jealous or
whatever that happens um but I I I do
think that we have
neglected our you know spiritual life in
this country to a certain extent I think
that it it's not a good thing that we
have elevated atheism and that we have
expected the you know judeo-christian
moral codes as exemplified by you know
primarily yeah the Ten Commandments in
The Gospel according to Matthew um you
know the Beatitudes there I think it's a
a problem that we have expected those
things to survive in public life uh we
have expected the Civil religion that
maintains public Society to survive
while
removing God entirely while removing you
know the concept of a higher power that
will hold you accountable and that will
also not just hold you accountable that
will hold you accountable and provide
you light and love you know and
communion with your with your fellow man
I think that that's a big problem like
how do you this is a conversation I've
been having with my son a great deal
lately who's studying for his
confirmation next year um and definitely
says to me things like I don't know if I
believe in God and I'm like okay you
know enjoy your CCD class cuz you know
we're teaching you this anyway um and I
had you know a very long period of
toying with atheism myself until the
void was just too much the void was too
much I just I could no longer look into
that void and step out into the world
and look at the Sun and be happy about
it so but I think that um I think that
as we have removed God and as we have
removed spiritual feelings we have uh
eradicated them to the point where it's
hard to find them like how are the kids
supposed to find God if they never even
learn the word I was talking to and then
I'm going to let you talk I just have
one more thing I say I was um I was at
tpsa something not this past June but
the previous June and I was on a panel
with um Carol Martz and Emma Joe Morris
and it was really fascinating and we
were talking about how to maintain you
know your religious traditions and your
faith while you're living living in
essentially New York City where we lived
um and a young woman got up and she said
you know most of us in my generation
don't know anything we know we don't
know from God we don't understand any of
this uh instead when we have a spiritual
crisis we think it's psychological and
we go get therapy and we just end up
with drugs so how do you how do you find
God if God has been eradicated and how
do you maintain a moral Center if there
is nothing to ground it yeah do you do
you find that religion is uh in in the
time that you've been alive if you found
like the the the decrease in religion
here in America to be one of the main
calling cards for wise Society seems to
be falling the way it
has yes yeah um I can remember
when there was and I think lib you make
a very important
Point everyone sort ort of
agreed on the basics of ethical
Behavior but the feeling was well we
don't we don't have to be
so doctrinaire about religious faith we
can you know you don't even really need
to be religious to acknowledge that
killing is bad and uh you know stealing
is bad but it turns out that that's not
true it turns out that that's not true
true at all because we see widespread
justification of killing and we see
stealing both of those are both highly
Justified now in society right um and
this is something that I discussed and
in fact I discussed it with with
um uh at length with with our mutual
friend um on the Sheamus on the shammer
cast
shast after we after we met here when
you were pretending to be so
you skip
work
um it is extremely difficult because you
know he he's a he's an orthodox Catholic
and I'm an orthodox Jew and we were
talking
about you know we might all agree as a
completely objective sociological
observation that
societies that do have religious Faith
are more stable
and there might be aspects of it
but you what do you do if people have
lost their faith as a societ when as an
entire in
society well you know that didn't really
necessarily work I mean you know oh I
was
kidding oh no I I you know if it worked
then we would have to you know but
actually remember the main issue with
the with the Inquisition was
identifying Jews who pretended to be
converts um but
you can't even really talk about
Orthodoxy anymore in other words we're
we're we're in a we're in a post
Orthodoxy World unless you live in a
subculture as I do in
which we have created our own governing
mores and it's not perfect and it's not
entirely always consistent but be
because of the the extent of Liberty
that Americans are
permitted and most people in the west
are permitted we can we can do that and
we have our own internal governance
systems and our own retical Courts for
civil disputes and again everything
doesn't click the way it necessarily
ought to
but what can you do to an entire society
that doesn't even have
that feeling that because you know Libby
you identified you know You' reached a
point in your life when you said
this I'm going to paraphrase you now
this can't be what it's all about M this
we're just an
arbitrary fart of the
universe there must be meaning there
must be a reason and there must be truth
and there must there must be somewhere
that love comes from was also what I was
thinking
and you still had resonating in you a
family tradition of where to look to
recover the
the you know the methodology and the
language and the thinking of what the
answers to these questions were so my
friend um yuram honei writes in his you
know books about conservatism and
National
conservatism it is a legitimate thing
for people to look to the faith of their
ancestors people think well how do you
know Judaism how do if you would have
been born a Hindu I
wasn't I wasn't I just know that the
people that that I respect and the and
the tradition and the culture
that I look to my ancestors toward and I
see people who were older than
I they are a product of a tradition that
is entitled to a presumption of validity
for me because I am myself also a
product to that that's very hard for
Americans to get onto because Americans
have this admirable quality of
questioning
everything and being skeptical and show
me state I'm from Missouri you
know
and it turns out that these those are
good exercises to participate in but you
if you don't have a base at which you
say this is never
permitted and and also you know there's
there's such a lack of understanding of
basic theological
Concepts that have been treated at Great
length for thousands of years and people
go to college and they think they
they've you know they've got these
really clever answers to Great
theological questions and they
don't and they think it's really a good
question so you think God really cares
whether you uh eat bacon or
not I do and you know why because God
has the capacity to care about
everything at once he's not limited like
you are by trying to multitask he's God
uh and and it would be great if you know
May and you know there probably are
people who do this if people could un
you know could could get a B basic
theological
education uh and just understand if they
want to be Skeptics what they're being
skeptical of but it's a hard it's a real
hard task what are the ramifications
for uh defying God in Judaism
is in traditional
Judaism there are several kinds of
punishments that are discussed uh in the
Torah one is that if you uh you can be
punished by an
Earthly um court
for knowingly violating God's law now
you can also in the time of the of the
temple you know the Great temple of
Palestine in Jerusalem uh that you could
you would bring a sacrifice You' have to
bring a sacrifice
because you know that that's laid out in
the you know in the Bible as how you
atone for a sin you have to go through
the trouble of buying an animal and
having it you know and it doesn't have
to be a big old cow it could be a bird
it could it could even just be meal if
you're if you're if you're a poor person
you need to say to
God I I'm making a donation I'm I am
paying a penalty and I want and and and
you're gonna you fine what if you don't
if you don't then all right let's your
question really is more spiritual not
phys right so you can be punished in
this
world which is considered to be a good
scenario in other words you would rather
be punished In This World by afflictions
than have your punishment await you in
the next world because there's no
limitation to what suffering you can uh
experience in the next world but is this
the same notion of Heaven and Hell
essentially essentially it is I mean
there are you know and there's a lot of
I I will tell you that the the
traditional Jewish thinking on this has
reflected in the talmid and this is
going to get your live chat going they
love words like that
um the the rabbis or absolutely
comfortable with the idea of reward and
Punishment in the in this world in the
next World we also have the uh the
concept of the
um the
the that the dead will come will come
back to life in the time of you know of
the
Messiah you can be deprived of the
opportunity to be resurrected if you if
if you are guilty of certain certain
kinds of sins um which would be you know
that would be pretty bad but then
there's you know there's a soul the soul
is not the body the soul is not you it's
not some you know it's not some magnetic
force or something it's it is it is a a
Godly Essence that is placed with within
you and it's you can suffer in this
world you can suffer in the next World
very comp you know much much more
complex stuff than people would think
and you find you you know and it's
reflected in Christianity it's reflected
certainly in the cath the Catholic
church was founded by rabinal students
and they knew it you know they knew what
they were talking about thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8: pm and become a
member over at timcast.net